last friday i covered a hearing under
oath at which radical repugnant
congresswoman marjorie taylor greene
testified
uh and the point of the hearing was to
ascertain
whether she incited an insurrection on
january 6. the idea is
if green incited the insurrection
she can't run in 2022 because you're not
allowed to incite an insurrection and
then hold office so there was this
hearing she was under oath now she
repeated that she didn't remember
just about anything she was asked did
you ever suggest to trump that he uh put
in place martial law and she said i
don't remember
did you ever say that nancy pelosi
should be shot she said oh i don't
remember and
on and on and we all knew that she was
lying we know she remembers but i don't
recall is a legal strategy because
you're not denying that you said it
which can be proven wrong you're just
saying you don't remember and the idea
is i don't remember i don't remember i
don't remember they can't prove i'm
lying this goes away now we know that
she committed heavy perjury and we're
going to look at some examples many of
you will email me and you'll say david
you're not in a position to say whether
it's perjury because you don't know what
was in her mind perjury
is state of mind do you know that when
you say i don't remember you actually do
remember and i can see that we're not in
a courtroom here what we are saying is
unless she has serious dementia
it's not plausible
that she didn't remember anything that
was disadvantageous but then when her
lawyer starts asking her the details of
what happened on january 6 jesus well at
1 30 we were moved into a secure
location and then i received a text
telling us that there had been shots
fired and oh now you do remember so
we're in a court of public opinion here
on the david pakman show and it's
obvious that she committed very heavy
perjury let's look at some examples here
um marjorie taylor green let's see if we
can get these up marjorie taylor green
on january 17th
texted mark meadows and said in our
private chat with only members several
are saying the only way to save our
republic is for trump to call for
martial law i by the way instead of
marshall m-a-r-t-i she spells it
marshall like the name
m-a-r-s-h-a-l-l which is we're not even
gonna get into that that's funny too i
don't know on those things i just wanted
you to tell him they stole this election
we all know they will destroy our
country next please tell him to
declassify as much as possible so we can
go after biden and anyone else so she
said to mark meadows uh i want you to
tell him people martial law communicate
to him that martial law is something
that should be considered and then
she was asked during the hearing about
this and here's what she said
uh ms green did you advocate to
president trump to impose martial law as
a way to remain in power i don't recall
so you're not denying you did it you
just don't remember i don't remember
okay all right well maybe that one she
genuinely doesn't remember
well uh she was also asked
what were you thinking
when
all of the invasion started happening of
the capital who did you think was doing
it and she said well we thought it was
antifa or black lives matter and
when you
were notified
that people had entered the capitol
illegally did you also understand that
point that there had been violence at
the capitol
i only knew what i was told i'd heard
i'd heard a gunshot we all heard it
and
we were so confused we thought antifa
was breaking in or blm because of those
were the riots that had gone on and on
all throughout 2020 day in and day out
so she says in the moment they thought
that it was antifa or black lives matter
rioting at the capitol even though we
all knew it was the trump people who
were at the rally they just walked and
started writing at the capitol but it
doesn't even seem that she believed that
because we now have another text
that she sent to mark meadows as this
was going on where she said mark i was
just told there's an active shooter on
the first floor of the capitol
please tell the president to calm people
this isn't the way to solve anything
nothing there about we think it's antifa
nothing about we think it's black lives
matter and more pointedly
if it was antifa or black lives matter
they're not going to listen to trump
saying calm down why would trump calm
down his enemies trump would only be
able to calm down the people on his side
so another example she obviously knew
obviously knew that the people there
were trumpists last example for today
although there's many more
during marjorie taylor green's under
oath hearings she was asked about a
capital rioter named anthony aguero
and
in the testimony
she said he's a distant friend i've not
spent much time with him he's just a
distant friend although aguero referred
to marjorie taylor green as a great
friend as a close friend well there is
now deleted video marjorie taylor green
has deleted this video
where she said
he is a great friend of hers take a look
at this because my friend anthony is my
dear dear friend
my dear dear friend anthony not a
distant friend no no my dear dear friend
i love him so much he's one of the
greatest guys i know one of the greatest
guys i know i love him so much
so just another example of the obvious
perjury when marjorie taylor green said
i don't remember i don't recall not
really my friend i don't really know now
i'm right there with you to be
prosecuted for perjury
is very difficult you have to prove she
knew she was lying you have to prove she
did remember so it's strategic memory
loss and by every legal analysis i've
seen it's an effective strategy but she
obviously lied we'll have these clips on
our instagram at david pakman show
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the only subscription streaming service
that specializes in documentaries my
audience can get a curiosity stream
subscription for only about a dollar a
month at curiositystream.com
pacman we all know netflix then hulu
they have some documentaries but
curiosity stream has a way better
selection in every category i'm always
finding documentaries on curiosity
stream i can't find anywhere else i just
watched electing lincoln which is a
three-part series about what led to the
election of abraham lincoln fascinating
absolutely fascinating curiosity stream
has an app for all of your devices i've
always got it going on the tv or i can
do put it on my tablet when i travel
with curiosity stream i can explore a
new topic i never knew i'd be interested
in or
zone out with a great nature documentary
whatever you're looking for it's there
and you can get curiosity stream for
just 14.99 a year that's less than two
bucks a month when you go to
curiositystream.com pacman and use the
code pacman the link is down below